yeah we have a guest coming in right now
and he's got a WWE Championship match
coming up at WrestleMania which is
unbelievable based on the story that's
been told ladies and gentlemen Kofi
Kingston is here what's going on man how
are you I'm fantastically well you know
just uh hanging and banging walking and
talking you know what I mean big media
day today but it's all good everything
is great yeah how is it doing media
right now without you've been in a group
called the new day yes four years and
you guys are joined at the hip you got
your new day shirt on usually you walk
around in matching tracks you know I
mean it's family and you wait and you do
media together all yes this it's very
strange so I actually had a me today in
Baltimore a couple days ago for
Smackdown and that was by myself I was
on the Fallon show last night that was
alone so I guess it's a good thing
because we're all like doing different
things we have all you know are our
hands in a lot of different pots right
now yeah and we're kind of diversifying
but um it's definitely very strange to
be doing a media day solo do you feel
like it's that on some level WWE is
seeing how this goes we're putting him
in the WWE Championship match let's see
if he can shine by himself oh I don't I
have no idea I mean they I've even
before a new day that I would do me
today's by myself so I don't know if
that would be like a you know like a
test I would hope they think that I can
handle it by now you know 11 years being
a you know odd on television with the
WWE like you guys know I was here before
new day you're a comic book guy right oh
yeah did Joker kill Batman's parents no
what no no no see this is somebody
literally just found out before you walk
Joe come on since in the Tim Burton
movie they showed Jack Nicholson killing
Batman's parents right and so for years
oh my god I've been living the truth
that's my truth oh my god and you really
give me like you're naked Wow
Kofi I mean do you so the story of Kofi
Kingston for those that don't know is
like you said you've been in WWE for 11
years you've been popular but never in
the
WWE Championship match I think it hasn't
happened for you
two months ago or so a couple months ago
one of the wrestlers ends up getting
injured and he's taken out of a match
legit and Kofi you get called in to be
his replacement in that match it was a
six-way Elimination Chamber match and
the lead-up to and that match itself
became so big and you became so you know
people were reminded of how much they
wanted you in that position I think that
the fans kind of forced the WWE's hand
into going wait a minute I don't know
what the plan was before but
WrestleMania is in a couple months I
think that Kofi is the one who needs to
get this WWE Championship yeah it's been
it's been surreal like the support from
the fans has been amazing and like you
said it's one of those things where like
you don't realize or I didn't realize
like how much they wanted this anyway I
knew that I wanted it round but it
wasn't until like you know that gauntlet
matched and I started getting to like
the last few people and people are just
like losing their minds I'm just like
wow this is amazing to see the support
because that's what you work for you
know I've always said that I have no
control over like the the booking or you
know where things are going to go the
only thing I can control is my
performance in the ring and I always try
to do that to the best of my ability you
know what I mean and it's it's paid off
you know and people have have have seen
that and noticed that and and and and
they want this as much as I do so it's
an awesome feeling to have that just
like you know unwavering support from
the WWE Universe when did you say to
yourself oh my god I think this is a
real possibility because clearly I mean
literally a week before the Elimination
Chamber right you you weren't in the
conversation you know even less yeah
yeah less than a week it was something
that so I remember and I've told the
story a few times like I I barely do
cardio like I'll lift but I don't like
I'm small enough as it is so for me to
be on the on the treadmill like burning
off more kind necessary calories it's
probably not the best thing so or I used
I use that as an excuse
not new car but uh you know I for
whatever reason decided to do cardio of
the Sunday before that Smackdown and
then I got a text at the show saying hey
you know Ally's gonna be hurt and he's
not gonna be in it we're gonna do a
gauntlet match you're gonna be the
replacement you know can you handle a
gauntlet match I'm just like yeah of
course but I was mad that like I did the
cardio before cuz my body's not used to
like having to like you know strain
itself so much I was like I wouldn't
have done cardio if I knew I was gonna
be in the ring for another hour but um
yeah I mean he did like it's a gauntlet
match that means you were in that match
for literally an hour yeah yeah but but
at the same time too like I've been
around long enough to know that these
opportunities are few and far between
and especially for me to even be like
spoken about in this this this title
picture was something that I knew that I
had to had to do well in you know what
I'm saying he has again like these
opportunities are so rare so it was my
only objective to kind of like knock it
out of the park and and I think we did a
pretty good job yes so is that what you
do you go like okay
I didn't know this morning when I woke
up this wasn't happening right but I've
got 50 minutes to shine in this gauntlet
match I have to be the guy who stands
out like not just so because it seems
like you know one strategy could be well
we want coffee to shine just so people
aren't disappointed that somebody was
replaced sir I don't think anybody
realized that Kofi's gonna shine so
bright that he starts out shining
everybody yeah yeah and being like
fortunate to be in that position as is
great and I've been using this quote for
a while but I just make sure to keep my
blade sharp you know what I'm saying
no matter what the just don't know like
you're always one match away you know
what I'm saying you don't realize it but
you're always you're literally one match
away from doing great things and you
know you just kind of have to keep going
out and having those great matches and
that always is the goal because you just
you just never know like what the
results of that performance is going to
be so that's easy for people to take
from you now in the context of you
proved it to be true but how do you
maintain that 411
years right 11 years you're going
through this and really I mean for me so
in 2009 you kind of flirted with the
idea of maybe you are gonna head towards
the main event I was at the Roy at a
story going with Randy Orton right I was
at that raw at Madison Square Garden Wow
where everybody did you had this but you
jumped off one of the sections in the
audience onto another section through a
table and everybody lost their minds and
everybody at that point in 2009 was
ready for Kofi Kingston yeah something
happened and it just got stopped in its
tracks
I feel like and it was like okay back to
where we were before with Kofi right so
to realize that yeah one match can
change everything but also it could be
taken away at a moment's notice
examine explore the show with every
single opportunity that you get so and
it does get hard sometimes weld this
story to like my first WrestleMania we
had the money in the bank I think it was
a 25th anniversary of Wrestlemania and I
did so many cool and amazing things that
had never been done before in a ladder
match was just saying a lot because you
know you have Christian and edge and the
Hardys and the Dudley's who have done so
many amazing things in ladder matches
and set the bar so high so when I was
able to kind of go out there and do
these amazing things that no one had
seen and then I come through gorilla and
everyone's are standing ovations I'm
like oh my god like things are about to
take off the very next day I'm not on
Raw so like it's like oh okay like I
just poured my heart and soul into this
and like I didn't get the result that I
wanted but okay let's try it again you
know now here we got the other orange
situation and going toe-to-toe with one
of the greatest of all time you know in
Madison Square Garden you know Roddy
Piper was involved in a segment I come
out to save Roddy Piper let's pause on
that forget about that I came out to
save hot rod Roddy Piper who is gonna be
the hero to save Roddy pace for me like
just weird man
but you know it was an amazing event
amazing match an amazing situation in
Madison Square Garden cuz a lot of
people know when you come to New York
like everybody tries to be cool and
cheer for all the bad guys know what I
mean so in the beginning of that
situation people were cheering for Orton
and I remember like getting beat up or
getting thrown over one of the guard
rails and everyone's like oh yeah get
him Randy look but by the end of that
segment when I was the one who was
jumping off the table onto him everybody
was on their feet chanting my name so we
were able to like turn people yes that
moment and it was organic it's real yeah
yeah so those are the moments that you
that you that you strive to have you
know the opportunities that you strive
to have and and take advantage of so you
you just do it you know what I mean it's
it's a guy said it's very hard I mean
it's very easy to like be jaded a lot of
the times when you put a lot into this
and you're not getting what you want but
like I said the only thing that I can
control is my performance you know so if
I get jaded and now I allow it to let my
performance slide then I deserve what or
I don't deserve to get you know through
to reap the benefits and have the the
the sweet fruits or whatever yeah so how
did you feel about the kind of the the
subtext of everything that's going on in
your storyline because the whole you
know anyone but us
yeah phrase you know I think that those
of us that look a little deeply kind of
know what's being said yeah and it's
pretty wild that that is being said and
being honestly said on WWE TV yeah you
know how do you feel about the fact that
that's part of this story well it's
great I think it's awesome because it is
kind of like the elephant in the room
you know I mean but at the same time it
when we say people like us everybody can
kind of relate to that because what does
it mean does it mean the fact that I
come out in like pigtails and we were
thank you bright colors and I skip can i
clap and I twerk and you know if you
don't want to see someone like that as a
WWE Champion you know what I mean yeah
so so we intentionally left it to be
kind of vague and there's a lot of
people who identify with it for a lot of
different reasons and oh I think what
the coolest thing about this storyline
is is that you know I mean going to like
a racial last
being an african-american male on
television doing great things we always
say it's so important to have
representation to where someone who
looks like you can look at the TV screen
and say wow this is possible for me he
looks like me I can do this but at the
same time it's also important for people
to identify with the fact that hey this
guy is fighting from underneath this guy
is having mountains put in front of him
he's climbing these mountains and then
more mountains are getting stacked on
top and he's still having to climb and
I'm having a trouble a difficult time in
my life well he's climbing these
mountains I can do that you know because
he's doing it so it's like Kendrick
Lamar said there's levels to it you and
I know to say it so it's uh it's it's so
many different levels and for us to
ignore that fact would do the whole
story like injustice so right just you
know we we're going out there and we
just kind of lay it all out on the table
and let it be what it is so I love that
that's the area that we're in or we're
like the truth is being set like the
things that the fans are talking about
or what's being reflected in the stories
there's not sort of things but just
being masked and being like I don't know
we're not gonna dress that like maybe
things are being addressed like I said
before - like it's it's it's bigger than
than just one thing but I think that
we're doing a good job of addressing all
of it especially me going out there and
you know the 11-year journey in and of
itself is crazy you know to have gone
through this for that long and only be
getting the chance now like that is like
the ultimate underdog you know keep
fighting as hard as you can because you
never know type situation as well so
like I said man there's levels to it and
just I think that's why so many people
are able to identify with this story is
because it covers so many different
aspects of life and gentlemen one more
gemandsam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM a